let's go to workout and
Recovery what have you learned in that
area because I know that you train like
you live
so yeah yeah I've been training for uh
what has it been 15 years now non-stop
it's a it's it's incredibly important um
so I have a lot to say on this but I
I'll keep it as brief as I can um when
it comes to training there's there's a
few fundamental things that people have
to do if they want to take advantage and
you're you're probably already doing all
of them but for anybody listening um one
is that you have to constantly be
progressively overloading um you have to
be improving in some form or fashion if
that's by the number of repetitions that
you perform the the the actual
resistance itself uh your rest times
whatever ends up being just picking a
metric and then trying to improve um
from exercise to
exercise um so Progressive overload is
is probably one of the highest tenants
that you can that you should always keep
in mind um the second one is definitely
not going to be new to anyone is going
to be lifting compound movements um so
we're talking about like a deadlift
squat bench press overhead press
pull-ups things of that nature just
multi-joint as long as you're not doing
uh dumbbell curls or tricep extensions
or whatever there's nothing wrong with
those exercises but for anybody first
starting out or even intermediately
lifter they should definitely be focused
a lot more on uh compound
lifting and the next one is uh volume is
the greatest driver of hypertrophy
so intensity when I mean by intensity
what I mean by volume let me explain
that real quick so intensity is just
literally the amount of weight that
you're lifting uh so the amount of
resistance that's on the end of the bar
or at the end of the cable or whatever
um volume is the actual amount of total
work done given a certain amount of time
so let's say if it's within a day so if
you go to the gym and you lift 5,000
pounds total for the day or you lift a
th000 pounds for your chest whatever it
might be um so or you can extend it to
per week or per month or however you
want to do it doesn't matter the point
is that you're lifting a certain amount
of weight and it has to be over a
certain amount of time and you can use
that as a metric so let's say month one
you were only a able to lift 8,000 lb uh
the next month you were able to lift uh
9,000 lb etc etc now there's an
intersect between those two in that you
can't be doing volume That's Just Junk
volume so you have to be putting in
enough resistance on the musculature
where you are actually stimulating
muscle growth now what does enough
resistance mean it's that the science
has become really clear on this this um
over the last 10 15 years that the
intensity doesn't matter nearly as much
as getting close enough to failure so
what I mean by failure is that you
literally just can't lift the weight
anymore so you would want to let's say
if if your failure reps would be let's
say you can do 12 repetitions of a
certain amount of weight if you can get
within like up to like 10 or 11
repetitions just a few reps shy that's a
that's definitely a good enough
intensity that you will see improvements
and muscle growth over time as long as
you continue to increase the volume over
time so so um thought here okay so I've
got a squat rack in my basement um I've
been I've been going down every 60 to 90
minutes throughout my workday and I'll
just go do some squats so if I'm pushing
you know let's say 8,000 last month but
in two or three months I'm I'm moving
15,000 pounds uh but I'm not lifting any
more weight or maybe even doing lighter
weight you know for example you're
saying that as long as I'm stressing the
money and money stressing the muscle and
moving volume of weight then that's
going to net a better outcome than
compound list or Progressive
overloading no it would still have to do
it would still have to be compound lips
and it would still have to be
Progressive overload but the progressive
overload can come through added volume
okay so because it's it's again the the
progressive overload is just am I
improving from one week to the next or
one month to the next so in that
scenario you are improving from that
month to the next um how you do it
doesn't really matter as long as you're
getting just sufficient intensity and
your volume is continuing to Rise um
that's but that's again specific to
muscle growth which doesn't it's it's
not a perfect correlation with muscle
strength like yes while the muscle size
increases the muscle strength increases
as well but I'm sure you've seen people
that are pretty skinny um they you know
they they don't have a ton of muscle on
them they're not like these super Jack
guys but they can lift a lot of weight
uh the reason for that is because they
they're focusing on strength or power
output Which is far more intensity based
as opposed to volume based so there's
you can mix and match these variables
but I know that a lot of people are
interested in kind of gaining a little
bit of both at the same time which
focusing on volume and then also pairing
that with a decent enough intensity
where you're you know getting within
about three to to four reps or closer to
to failure uh offers the the best bang
for your
book um okay so that's awesome um any
any hoaxes or anything that that we've
been lie to when it comes to um you know
workout recovery building muscle it's a
total waste of our time yeah there's
there's seems like an unending list it
feels like um what are the big ones that
pop to M right now well for example
confusing the musculature like infusing
the muscles that's just total BS um that
I just anybody no it's it your your
muscles don't get confused they they
don't have brains um they so what do you
mean by confusing them is like doing
different movements for the same muscle
like for example you can do cable like
rope pull downs and then do Skull
Crushers to hit the triceps in a
different way like is that what you mean
by confusing the muscle yeah I think
again I I I don't believe in it so I
you'd have to talk to somebody who
actually really believes in it but which
I think now is becoming fewer and fewer
people or maybe I'm just ignoring them I
don't know but um it I think the the
principle is yeah you you're you're
doing one exercise let's say one week
you're doing Skull Crushers then the
next week you're doing uh tricep pull
down but you're you're constantly moving
between those two exercises without
actually prioritizing am I improving in
these exercises it's just about mixing
it up as much as possible oh I didn't
get sore so from this exercise now I
have to move on to another exercise no
you should you should still be doing
that exercise you should just be
continuously trying to improve and it's
fine to switch exercises absolutely but
um just again make sure that improving
so are there any studies or anything
that you've come across that make any
recommendations for taking breaks on
workouts because I've noticed like if
you ever have to take a break for a
month or something like that and you go
back and your first workout you have
like immense amount of soreness and uh
like a positive feeling you know from
that workout is is that something that
they've studied yeah absolutely uh it's
been studied a lot so the differences
between d load and a um a just a
complete break uh this studies are
pretty clear on that as well so it's
typically recommended to do a D Lo which
means that you would be cutting your
volume at least in half and you'd be
cutting your intensity at least in half
so you're essentially just going in
there and just doing movement you're not
even like really you're you're lifting
the same a lightweight for like a month
or so yeah it's it's super easy I think
the D loads are typically supposed to be
one to two weeks but honestly if you
were to extend it further the point is
that if you're at least moving the
musculature you have a much higher uh
ability to retain that musculature even
if it's let's say a month I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full- length podcast you
can find that over here that clips from
if you're new to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out